all right so moving on next question for
eric uh i don't see the questioner's
name here but the question is
machines versus free weights for
hypertrophy which allows the greatest
volumes
and gains with four z's
yeah so there's a reason why i i uh
arranged the questions this way
because i think this question um you
know we have a little bit of
overlapping referencing so i think when
it comes to machines versus free weights
um one of the benefits to me
of machines are that they
they allow for additional variety as you
mentioned
and so for some people that variety
is going to meet their preferences
better like you said some people really
enjoy having that variety i intended to
talk a lot about that study by fonseca
at all that you talked about with
squats only versus a variety of
exercises
and i think that's really a place where
machines shine is
if you walk into a commercial gym
setting and you say like
yeah i want to get plenty of leg volume
but i don't want to just like
squat until i puke what's really great
is that the machines offer you a way to
target different muscle groups at
different angles
get a more uh varied stimulus for
hypertrophy so
you know the reason i want to bring up
that fonseca study
they compare the squat only versus squat
with
leg press deadlift and lunges obviously
only one of those is a machine
but certainly when you have a commercial
gym set up and all those machines at
your disposal
you can imagine that for a given amount
of total
number of sets for a leg workout it
really opens up the playbook
in terms of you know being able to give
a nice well-rounded stimulus for
hypertrophy
and one of the cool things about
machines or another cool thing is the
fact that machines can
be used with really minimal setup time
um
and without a great deal of skill or
experience you know
you could be working with an online
client who
maybe is beginner to intermediate with
skill level and you don't want to assign
them
really specialized free late free weight
accessory exercises that
either require a great deal of skill and
balance or
they might just not be advanced enough
they might not be ready for them yet
or frankly they might just be a pain in
the ass to set up
so it's like you know what we could also
just go to a hack squat machine
which hack squat machines are probably
among the most underrated machines that
you could possibly find in a gym
nothing better for the quads than a
well-made hack squat machine so
i think that machines certainly have a
place and i think
one of the things about machines that is
frustrating is that they've
developed such a bad reputation among
the the more like hardcore lifters
within certain pockets of the fitness
industry you know
there are certainly some uh some pretty
old school folks who are
are perceived to be pretty hardcore
lifters that still utilize all sorts of
machines you know
um but i think for a lot of people
they think like you know it's free
weights or bust basically but
machines uh they should very much be a
viable part of the uh
of the playbook that you have at your
disposal and
there is a study by fabricio rossi at
all
and so fabricio actually got a chance to
meet him when he was working with
jason kaliva down in coastal carolina a
really good guy really good researcher
and
in that collaboration with with jason
koleva they did a study looking at squat
versus
leg press and i think they had a third
treatment arm which was squat and
leg press and without getting really far
into the details of that study
basically what they found was from most
of their outcomes whether you were
squatting leg pressing or both
you were pretty fine the the the
outcomes were fairly similar
uh specifically when it comes to the
lean body mass changes they were they
were pretty much equivalent
with the three of those groups the
functional outcomes varied a little bit
and obviously when it comes to exercise
specificity is a very important
consideration
so there there are certainly some
physical tasks where
you can't just throw out in the squat
and say whatever i'm going to leg press
instead right
specificity absolutely is important to
keep in mind but when it you know the
question was specifically about
hypertrophy i think with hypertrophy i i
don't think it's fair to say that
machines
are better than free weights and i think
certainly you would want
assuming that you have uh you don't have
any constraints in terms of
injuries or skill level i still think
you want to build the base of your
program
around compound movements that are
likely to feature a lot of free weights
um but i don't see any reason to
consider free weights to be
unequivocally superior to machines when
the machines are utilized well within
the context of the program so
um my advice to people when it comes to
getting in your volume to promote the
hypertrophy you're looking for
just understand that free weight and
machine exercises are all
on the table i think for most people a
combination of the two is going to make
a lot more sense than going
really hard in one direction or the
other you can do just fine
in terms of hypertrophy if you're going
machines only
and you can do just fine for hypertrophy
if you're going free weights only so
i i don't think it's a dichotomy that is
particularly
uh constructive i i think you put
together a program you want to make sure
if hypertrophy is the goal you want to
make sure you have sufficient volume
and as we've talked about it might make
sense to make sure you have plenty of
exercise variety in the mix
and if some of those are machines no
problem at all
another cool thing about um utilizing
a variety of exercises this is something
we've touched on before which is kind of
a bit
of a tangent but uh i know for me
anecdotally i'm by no means
anywhere close to an expert on injury
or anything of the sort but if i just
hammer
a single lift in the same plane of
motion in the same angle in the same
direction
set after set after set day after day
that can really
bring a little bit of wear and tear to
the joints involved
and so sometimes a nice thing about
variety with your exercise selection
whether it's with
machines free weights or both is that
you're hitting things at different
angles
loading the joints a little bit
differently and the different tissues
that make up the joint
and it can be a nice a nice uh
beneficial aspect that you are giving
your joints a little bit of variety as
well and not overloading them
the exact same way set after set after
set
so that's uh that's my take do you have
any
anything to add when it comes to
machines greg yeah i mean i i think it
i think it largely depends on what
machine you're talking about
and what free weight exercise you're
comparing it to
so for example uh you mentioned a study
comparing
squats versus leg press and the thing
about squats and leg press
is they're pretty similar exercises
so in both cases they have a varied
strength curve
so there's a part of the range of motion
where you're weaker there's a part of
range of motion where you're stronger
and but they have flat resistance curves
so the amount of resistance a barbell is
pushing down
on you with is the same throughout the
range of motion
same thing with a leg press the amount
of force this the sled of the leg press
is pushing into your feet with
is the same throughout the range of
motion so those
are are fairly comparable exercises in
terms of comparing strength curve to
resistance curve
however if we look at something like
say a pec fly or a pullover and compare
that to like a peck deck or a really
high quality pullover machine
i think it could be a little bit
different hypertrophy wise so
if you do a full range of motion fly uh
you know
it's hard at the bottom by the time the
weight's a third of the way up it's
stupidly easy same thing with a pullover
uh
when the dumbbell is below your head or
near head level it's pretty challenging
um once you bring it probably four or
five inches above head level
it's super easy compare that to a pec
deck
which is specifically designed to be
able to keep tension on your pecs
through the entire range of motion
or like we've talked about on this
podcast before both eric and i
love a well-made pullover machine keeps
really great tension
on your lats and and probably the long
head of your triceps to some degree as
well
but really really great tension on your
lats through the entire range of motion
i would be a little surprised
if a pullover machine wasn't better for
lad hypertrophy than
a dumbbell or an easy bar pullover was
for lat hypertrophy
i'd be a little surprised if a pec deck
wasn't a little bit better for pec
hypertrophy than dumbbell flies were for
pec hypertrophy
so they have that benefit of being able
to
match strength curves to resistance
curves a little bit better or i guess
resistance curves to strength curves
like the way the cam systems are built
that's literally what they're designed
to do
and for some free weight exercises i
doubt that matters all that much
because the strength curve is relatively
flat
uh but for some free weight exercises i
do think that could make
quite a bit of a difference and give an
advantage to machines
and then another thing i would say is i
very much agree with
with eric that it's good to have variety
and i think i think sometimes you're a
little bit limited
variety wise with free weights in terms
of being able to pick
exercises where you can really make sure
uh
you're going to be limited by the target
muscle and can keep
you know good stress on that target
muscle so for example
if you're trying to train your quads and
you're doing free weight exercises
you have squats and some variety of
squats that's good
where do you go after that bulgarian
split squats
those are okay but until you get really
good at them do you really want to go to
failure because you know you could lose
your balance
well okay let's do dumbbell bulgarian
split squats
so if you start losing your balance you
just drop the dumbbells that's fine
but as you get stronger grip is going to
be become a limiter before
quad fatigue is um so
or you know like step ups or lunges
similar type things
um like balance could become an issue or
just getting other muscles involved
could start limiting you
before you actually are able to fatigue
the muscle that you're trying to fatigue
but if you open yourself up to
also using machines to get that variety
then you know you could do hack squats
that's always going to be limited by
your quads
or leg press which if you do it
correctly
can also always be limited by your quads
so in that case machines wouldn't
strictly be better but it's more like
you know for for some muscles there is a
tremendous amount of variety
you could achieve with just free weights
and for other muscles
you're you're going to be somewhat
limited with really good
exercise selection unless you open
yourself up to
to working some machines in as well